what's going on guys this is Rob and if
you're enjoying the content here on my
channel then make sure you hit the like
button and make sure you hit subscribe
so you can't decide what direction the
content on my channel goes in in the
foreseeable future all right so we're
finally here and a lot of you guys got
mad at me at the end of the last video
how dare you leave us on a cliffhanger
like that Rob what is your problem well
you know what cliff failures are how I
get you to come back so how about them
apples take that I am officially on the
tail end of this flu thank God because I
gotta say this thing was killing me by
the way happy new year guys I really
hope you guys had a safe and happy new
year there's a lot of crazies this time
of year so hopefully you guys are ever
staying safe and everything but what
this does is this brings us the
much-awaited conflict scar Son of Hulk
vs. world breaker Hulk not only that we
also get to see the Red Hawk fighting
world breaker home and needless to say
the fight probably goes exactly the way
you would expect it to you but there's a
really cool caveat to this so as we know
Jeff Loeb and Greg Pak have been drawing
a lot on the whole bill Matt Lowe Peter
David Ronn of The Incredible Hulk where
was the introduction of his abusive
father well you know how that abuse
basically manifested in the form of The
Incredible Hulk
as a second persona when Bruce Banner
was blasted with gamma radiation and it
really just sort of set the stage for
everything that came after with regards
to his characters development you know a
lot of those themes were kind of lost
over the years it was really cool to see
those ideas more or less brought back in
the form of this particular run of Hulk
and the incredible hulks
now what this also does is it gives us
some behind-the-scenes stuff in the
sense that Bruce Banner before absorbing
all the scandal radiation and returning
the x-men Avengers Deadpool returning
all those guys to the normal forms had
recorded a video diary of sorts and what
he basically said was he basically was
spending the last few months or so
manipulating all the different
superheroes of the world for the purpose
of consolidating all these
gamma-irradiated beings into one place
basically tricky the intelligence yet
and the idea was that if he was
successful the Intelligencia would
effectively be defeated but there was
also a very high chance that in the
process The Incredible Hulk would return
the issue with this is that if the
Incredible Hulk came back it wouldn't
just be a Incredible Hulk it wouldn't
just be a green Hulk running around it
would literally be all the gamma
radiation that was absorbed from The
Incredible Hulk the last time he was the
Hulk channel back into banner again
which means it would be the return of
world breaker Hulk all that anger all
that rage channeled right back
Bruce Banner and it would basically be
him picking up where he left off from
and what he says is if that happens if
the Incredible Hulk comes back the only
thing you could do is run but you cannot
defeat him you cannot fight him what
they need to do is they need to clear
out civilians and they need to make a
path for the hoax son to face up against
him since he's the only one that has the
hatred to actually have a chance of
pulling it off the problem here is that
he has no chance of pulling it off it's
hilarious to watch this happen because
to me it was always like in the back of
my mind I kind of figured this was gonna
happen yes it would be cool to see scars
on him Hulk going against world breaker
Hulk it always would have been cool to
see but in the back of my head I was
always like but there's no way he would
stand a legitimate chance right I mean
there's like no that's not gonna happen
I mean it's the strongest version of the
Incredible Hulk and history against a
guy who could control the tectonic
plates of the planet but doesn't have
unlimited strength I mean what like your
Hulk could break the planet in half it
doesn't really say a whole lot for Skaar
so the result here is that again the
conflict they're having the fight that
they're engaging in is shaking the earth
at its very core
not only that because of the fact that
Skaar seems to be absorbing the tectonic
energies of the earth basically
absorbing the energy that The Incredible
Hulk is putting off whatever it is that
he's stepping on the ground or stomping
on the ground because remember with each
step that he takes it shakes parts of
the planet - the Avengers - all these
the recipie heroes it looks like Skaar
is the one that's trying to break the
planet apart what a reality all scars
doing is absorbing as much energy as he
can so that when his father charges at
him he literally punches what Bricker
Hulk with the force of the planet Earth
and what this means is that Earth is not
enough because world breaker Hulk
immediately covers and pummels the hell
out of scar and this is just this was so
cool because it's like I've been waiting
for this you know like as I've been
asking this the entire time who would
win in a fight scar Center Hulk vs.
world breaker Hulk and Wilbert and
holdest Thompson he's like look I could
crush you easily but I'm not here to
fight you I could take you out and it'd
be no questions asked I could kill you
right now if I wanted to now scar tries
to go to his father into fighting he
says look Kyra always said that you were
good always said that you were strong
but in the eyes of scar The Incredible
Hulk is weak now remember Hulk does not
know about scars time on Sekar he
doesn't know that Kyra the old strong
her spirit lived on as part of the car
because she was one of the old strong
because she literally had the power to
get
the planet itself she was part and
parcel to it he basically learns this
through scar in the form of taunts when
Hawk says no no no Kairos dead there's
no way you could have talked to her and
scarce isn't enough she lived through
the planet sakaar she lived through the
rocks itself she was alive at least she
was until I fed the planet to Galactus
wrong answer The Hulk freaks like he
absolutely loses his mind and again he
started like lashing out at scart and
this is where the Peter David this is
guy this is beautiful gun this is where
the Peter David and bill Mantlo stuff
begins to come into play here what we've
always assumed it's the reader is that
when the Hulk is saying just leave me
alone why don't you leave me alone did
he's always talking about the people
that he's facing off against this is
what I say some of these elements were
lost under the Peter David run it was
really starting to build mad low but
under the Peter David run the incredible
hulks father you know Bruce banners
abusive father was always resonating in
the back of his mind that was one of the
reasons why the Incredible Hulk became a
Horsemen of apocalypse because
apocalypse when Truman said look I will
remove the essence of your father
taunting you in your mind if you'll
agree to become my horseman and Hulk was
like deal you know so he became a
horseman of apocalypse of course up the
effects were off you know and afterwards
returned to his normal form his father's
spirit came back but his father was
constantly talking of all the time
constantly making fun of him constantly
being mentally abusive to him and so
that's what Hulk was lashing out at the
entire time was always leave me alone he
was always you know lashing out at his
father whenever he saw people attacking
him he saw his father attacking him and
so that's really what the scar picks up
on here because when war breaker Hall
turns the table on scars a scar does not
see it coming and hope pushes him into
the atmosphere brings him back down to
earth again and just starts beating the
absolute star out of him scar begins to
come to the realization that no one else
knows about this no one else is aware of
the fact that when the Incredible Hulk
is saying leave me alone that he's
talking to his father he's not talking
to the people that he's fighting against
and so this is why scar says look no one
knows you no one really understands what
it is that you're about no one really
grasp what it is it's going on inside
that head of yours they don't really
understand you the way that I understand
you and so because of this this was
really The Incredible Hulk coming to the
realization that with each hit that he
makes on scarred with each attack then
he makes on his son he is his father
he's playing out the role of his father
he's abusing the hell out of his son
just like his father abused the hell out
of him now the circumstances are a bit
different here though and this is
I'm not a hundred percent on board with
what it is that Jeff lobe and Greg Pak
were doing here the theme I understand
the overall ideology I can get behind
but the father of Bruce Banner was just
a horrible human being I mean he was
just a cruel person who beat his son at
every turn because he could not because
he had to in this situation
scarce challenging his father he
literally ran up on him and just started
beating the crap out of him first he has
an inherent desire to kill his father
you know patricide and so because that
is a totally different scenario here but
even in that realm you know even in that
logic The Incredible Hulk says I can't
keep doing this I cannot keep beating on
my son and so he effectively just backs
off and what this does is this sort of
allows Banner to kind of end this cycle
of violence so to speak and to go
towards his own son and basically say
you are my son you are my progeny my
offspring even if I didn't want to
accept them before I have to accept it
now and so what this does is just kind
of create a reconciling between the two
is essentially just the fact that the
Incredible Hulk
realizes and recognizes that scar is the
son which is extremely important because
once we get into hero kala we're gonna
realize that Hulk needs all the allies
he can get so switching over to Red Hulk
because those you guys who don't know
hero colwiz like the second son of Bruce
Banner and that dude is a dick like he's
awesome but he's a god he's mad he's
rough alright so when it comes to Red
Hawk lead essentially just ended last
time with what seemed to be taking over
the White House ribbing the head off the
life model decoy of a general Talbot
revealing to the world that he was
actually a machine but in light of all
this we have basically a world breaker
Hulk show up here now we don't really
get a connection here I mean you know
Greg Pak and Jeff love don't really mend
the rift between how we got from point A
to point B it's really just that we're
here now but at the very least it just
kind of allows us to see the two of
these guys fighting against one another
but keep in mind if scar didn't stand
much of a chance against world breaker
Hulk general Thunderbolt Ross has a
stand any chance at all but again this
is really just kind of going through and
providing some reconciliation all these
different plot threads because remember
for the longest time the idea was that
general Thunderbolt Ross had just turned
on the intelligencia after becoming Red
Hawk he started executing his own agenda
but there really didn't seem to be a
common theme between general Thunderbolt
losses Red Hulk and Bruce Banner as The
Incredible Hulk
aside from Betty Ross herself and that's
still the idea here it's still the one
thing that the two of them share but
it's also this reconciliation
they effectively meet each other but
then we're also going to learn that
banner has a much bigger plan here the
offer Ross again it's the idea of just
stopping the incredible hole in his mind
right now he has the power to do that
it's his overriding goal and it's like
the Terminator franchise every
terminator regardless of what they're
programmed to do has a singular program
an overriding program in the back of
their mind kill John Connor on site
they'll stop whatever they're doing if
they see John Connor and then we'll
media to go after and they'll kill him
and it's an ongoing thing with Red Hulk
is exactly the same way he's got his own
agendas he's got his own motivations he
worked alongside Bruce Banner although
he hated banner but as soon as the
Incredible Hulk shows up everything else
gets cast aside and it's time to fight
the Incredible Hulk and kill him now the
kicker about this is again Red Hulk gets
very very haughty and very very arrogant
here I mean his hubris is off the scales
and the reason why is because of the
fact that he considers himself so
powerful in terms of his strategy in
terms of his body he'd you know in terms
of the energy he puts off his ability to
absorb gamma energy the fact that he
sits down and says I was able to defeat
The Incredible Hulk before I can defeat
you again the difference is that even
after letting off what amounts to a
nuclear explosion it doesn't make any
difference because this is not the
Incredible Hulk that Red Hulk fought
before this is world breaker Hulk which
means that he's got to be on his a game
and he's not because worl rekr Hulk
immediately turns the tables on him and
basically just beats the living tar atom
to the point he literally claps his
hands and sends him flying into
Washington DC into the lakid monument
now when they get there this is when we
learned the ulterior motive of Bruce
Banner and this is actually where we
learned what it is the Jeff Love and
Greg Pocket wanted to do from here
because by having general Thunderbolt
Ross become the Red Hook there was no
going back I mean you can't go back to
him being general Thunderbolt Ross
because nobody would care anymore you
know I mean I wouldn't care about
reading stories with general Thunderbolt
Ross I care about reading stories that
have read Hulk in it you know because he
was such a compelling character and it
was so cool to read and so what happened
is Hulk you know again because this is
world breaker Hulk because he has all
the rationality intelligence and the
memories of Bruce Banner basically what
he says here is the entire idea what's
to work all sides it was to basically
destroy all of his enemies or defeat all
of his enemies with one fell swoop the
idea was to basically say okay let's
take out the intelligence here by
turning their devices against him by
irradiating the world's superheroes
forcing the intelligence to his hand
allowing Bruce Banner to be captured
we could turn around and be free using
the powers of dr. doom and so on to
liberate all the other superheroes the
other idea was to basically have Red
Hulk kill general Thunderbolt Ross
because to the eyes of the world general
Thunderbolt Ross is dead which means if
Red Hulk were to go back into general
Thunderbolt Ross form it would result in
his arrest because of the some of the
shady things that general Thunderbolt
Ross had did most notably treason and so
because of this Ross is stuck in his Red
Hulk form he can never go back to being
general Thunderbolt Ross or at least not
in the immediate future he can't go back
to being a general Thunderbolt Ross
there will be a couple times here and
there when he will change back to his
normal human form but for the most part
he's just going to stay in his red hole
form but that's basically the curse he
says look this is how things are going
to be your life is going to be like my
life at all you have now is your a
platform nothing else everything that
you love everything you care about is
gone Betty Ross hates you she's alive
but she hates you you have the world
superheroes who know or who find out
that if you are general Thunderbolt Ross
they'll have you arrested
but you'll literally spend the rest of
your life in a prison cell it's
basically saying like this is your life
now
you can never be a general Thunder well
Ross again and so because of this he
ends up actually taking him to the gamma
base anyway and throwing him in a prison
cell now he's put there for an
unspecified amount of time we don't know
exactly how long it is that he's there
for all we know is that we basically
have the Incredible Hulk and we have to
Steve Rogers this point it's not really
Captain America's as Bucky Barnes is
still Captain America but Steve Rogers
and The Incredible Hulk
ended up going down to the cell where
red Hook's being held and they're
essentially asking for us help now we
don't know what is helps being asked for
yet well I mean at least within the
confines of the story we didn't know but
now this woman right now they're
actually going to recruit Red Hulk for
some rather secret missions some some
unsavory missions but what this does is
this basically wraps up world Warhawks
this brings an end to that World War
Hulk storyline and what this actually
did is it allowed for kind of this
relaunch so to speak of the Incredible
Hulk line of stories and the Red Hulk
line of stories and a lot of Marvel or
basically though for we're doing
whatever is they wanted to do with this
character it basically kind of set the
stage for future stories films just kind
of experiment and see what it is they
wanted to do but in an even if you guys
are new here to comment explain make
sure you guys hit the subscribe button
to become part of the Rob core you guys
enjoyed this video make sure you drop a
like and yeah I will catch you all later
peace
[Music]